amy coney barrett joins the supreme
court democrats lose their minds and the
media continue to white knight for joe
biden as we move one week from the 2020
election i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be public protect yourself
at expressvpn.com ben
alrighty so in just a second we're going
to get to everything news related we'll
get to all of the polls and everything
else first
let me talk to you about a really
interesting sort of investment that is
available to you art
is one of the oldest and largest asset
classes in the world usually it's
reserved for the ultra rich
i mean you're very very wealthy and now
you can afford to buy a renoir painting
and you have stored your wealth and it's
only going to accrue
over time but you can't afford a renoir
painting instead what you need is
masterworks it's the first platform that
lets anybody invest in art at a fraction
of the normal price
now you can buy and sell shares of
multi-million dollar paintings by blue
chip artists like andy warhol
basquiat banksy and more as easily as
trading
stocks did you know that only one
percent of day traders actually turn a
profit so why are so many of us
mistaking picking stocks for serious
investing
you really should instead put something
in like a long-term proposition that's a
long-term proposition
art right blue chip art if that sounds
unusual you're not alone but ultra
wealthy people have been doing this for
literally centuries from 2000 to 2018
art performed the s
the outperform the s p by an incredible
imagine being able to invest in the very
same paintings as millionaires and
billionaires at a fraction of the cost
go check them out at masterworks.io it's
an exclusive platform that makes it easy
as trading stocks online their experts
will create a custom portfolio to meet
your investment needs with
masterworks.io
you don't have to choose between big
risks and big returns sign up today with
promo code ben
you can skip the 25 000 person wait list
to get first dibs again that is
masterworks dot io
promo code ben hurry the software
expires students see important
information at masterworks dot io slash
disclaimer go check them out right now
it's a really interesting
and cool way to invest okay so
last night amy coney barrett she of the
handmaid's tale
seven kids catholic obviously
subservient to men
she joined the supreme court so it was a
straight party-line vote the only
member of the republican party who voted
against her susan collins in maine who
is running a losing race
right now to sarah gideon in in maine
and uh and so barrett joined the court
there was a ceremony at the white house
people were very angry there was a
ceremony in the white house but of
course there's been a ceremony at the
white house
for nearly every supreme court pick of
the last 20 years ruth bader ginsburg
had one sotomayor had one elena kagan
had one
this is nothing new it's just people who
hate trump are mad that amy coney
barrett went to the white house
at all and president trump spoke at this
event
he suggested this was a momentous day
for the constitution of the united
states
this is a momentous day for america
for the united states constitution and
for
the fair and impartial rule of law
the constitution is the ultimate
defense of american liberty the faithful
application of the law
is the cornerstone of our republic that
is why as president
i have no more solemn obligation and no
greater honor
than to appoint supreme court justices
and president trump continued and he
said it was fitting that any coney
barrett would fill ruth bader ginsburg
seat this of course
was designed to lead to endless nights
of screaming for
democrats who are very very upset that
ruth bader ginsburg who
of course was on the wild left of the
court who decided that the constitution
was basically to be read
like left-wing poetry that she is going
to be supplanted by amy
coney barrett who obviously is a
textualist and a constitutionalist and
an originalist who believes that laws
actually mean what they say and say what
they mean
here is president trump speaking about
amy coney barrett and rbg
it is highly fitting that justice
barrett
fills the seat of a true pioneer for
women
it's justice ruth bader ginsburg
tonight justice barrett becomes not only
the
fifth women to serve on our nation's
highest court
but the very first mother of school-aged
children to become a supreme court
justice very important
now of course you're not seeing a lot of
female solidarity i just noticed this i
noticed this from all the same people
who said that there's a special place in
hell for women who don't stand alongside
other women i'm noticing not a ton of
sympathy for amy cody bear not a lot of
talk about
the historic nature of this very
historic pick and when it's kamala
harris
who is picked for vice president because
specifically joe biden said that he
wanted a woman of color for his
vp then it's a very historic
historically big historic pick
even though we've had a female nominee
for the democratic party as president
we have had a black president of the
united states who was a democrat but
kamal harris was the most historic of
all historic people because of her
historic historic nature because she's
historic
amy coney barrett however who is a
mother of seven joining the supreme
court that is not historic
in any way nor is that really worthy of
note because obviously she's a
conservative which means she's not a
real woman
real women back abortion according to
the left and if you are not an overt
backer of abortion
this means you no longer count in the
female brotherhood
i will say the the sisterhood it is
pretty amazing
that according to the left what makes
you a woman
what makes you a woman is being in favor
of abortion or also possibly being a man
right if you're if you're a man and you
declare you're a woman then you're a
woman but if you're a woman who is
anti-abortion then you're no longer a
woman
so the standards i feel of femininity
have really taken a a
weird left turn when it comes to the
democratic party and to the left
uh in in the united states culturally
speaking clarence thomas swore in amy
coney barrett which of course was a
pretty historic moment you have a
black justice on the supreme court
swearing in a female justice on the
supreme court
which is a pretty cool thing right i
mean for all of those who believe that
america is not diverse that there are no
opportunities
open to black americans or to female
americans that america is just one big
land of glass ceilings
kind of a weird picture especially
because president trump is the one
presiding over it clarence thomas of
course is appointed by a republican amy
coney barrett is appointed
by a republican here was clarence thomas
swearing in amy coney bear didn't notice
any talk about the historic historic
nature of this historic moment
because again for democrats historic is
just code for things we like
and if it's a thing they don't like then
it just doesn't count
but it is kind of historic that you have
a a black man who's the son of
sharecroppers
swearing in a catholic mother of seven
that seems like kind of a cool thing no
worthy of note by the meat no no not
just kind of a normal day in washington
dc i guess
okay here's what that looked like i
amy tony barrett you solemnly swear that
i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
that i will support and defend the
constitution
of the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic against all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
so help me god so help me god
okay so that is a pretty cool thing
right though she was being sworn in
then she spoke briefly and uh she
pointed out once again that her judicial
philosophy suggests that it is not her
job to legislate from the bench and once
again a thousand whales were heard
across the land
where democrats said no no the job of
the supreme court is to do all of our
bidding and if the supreme court refuses
to do our bidding
then we don't want the supreme court to
exist at all as we'll see this is going
to become
a major talking point for many democrats
as they talk about packing the supreme
court here is amy coney barrett
explaining what used to not have to be
explained which is that the job of a
judge is not to actually make the law
but to interpret the law as written
honestly this is like having a plumber
speak about how the job of a plumber
is not to create wholly new plumbing
systems in a house
generally right that's that's for that's
for rare occasions
generally the job of a plumber is to
simply
fix your toilet right i mean the job of
a judge is to interpret the law as it is
written it is not to completely remake
the constitution
every time a case comes before them in a
mold that they would wish to see
here's amy coney barrett saying what
used to be basically assumed
it is the job of a judge to resist her
policy preferences
it would be a dereliction of duty for
her to give in to them
federal judges don't stand for election
thus they have no basis for claiming
that their preferences reflect those of
the people
this separation of duty from political
preference
is what makes the judiciary distinct
among the three branches of government
so
um i don't know why that had to be said
except that the left doesn't believe
that that's true so it does actually
have to be
said well over in the senate obviously
democrats were fighting mad mitch
mcconnell
spoke before the vote and he said listen
elections have consequences
you guys violated every single mormon
and it is important to
recapitulate what democrats have done
about judges over the years because
they're now claiming that this was
unprecedented as we'll see
um democrats violated every single norm
about judges and then they are upset
when they have to live by the new norms
they created democrats decided that it
was worthwhile to bork robert bork
going after him on the basis of judicial
philosophy and suggesting that because
he believed that it was his job to
interpret the law rather than make the
law this meant that he was a racist
sexist bigot
and so they borked borg then they
attempted to
sink justice clarence thomas with
bizarre allegations about
jokes about pubic hairs on coke cans
then
they decided that it would be worthwhile
to filibuster judges right that had not
been done before they decided they were
going to filibuster miguel estrada back
when george w bush was president
then they decided to kill the judicial
filibuster right they killed the
filibuster with regard to judges in 2013
because harry reid didn't like the
republicans we're now using a tool that
he had created with
along with other democrats in order to
stop bush judges from getting appointed
so republicans started using that tool
so he killed the judicial filibuster
and then republicans finally just rammed
through judges on the basis of all of
these
all of these various heresies by
democrats also worth noting in in that
little litany right there the democrats
also decided to
falsely allege that a supreme court
judicial nominee for the republicans was
a gang rapist
that one happened in the last couple of
years so here's mitch mcconnell saying
you guys violate every norm
and then you're surprised when you use
the the baseline
democratic process in order to confirm a
judge just like every other judge has
ever been confirmed in american history
here was uh here is here's mitch
mcconnell our democratic colleagues keep
repeating the word illegitimate
as if repetition would make it true
you just say it often enough does it
make it true i don't think so
we're a constitutional republic
legitimacy does not flow
from their feelings
you know legitimacy is not the result of
how they feel about it
you know you can't win them all and
elections have consequences
okay first of all really enjoying
cocaine mitch paraphrasing my
catchphrase there
legitimacy does not care about your
feelings but that is of course exactly
right
and democrats are now complaining that
this whole process is illegitimate
you're out of court you're out of order
this whole court is out of where al
pacino land and justice for all
right this is he he is correct about
this legitimacy does not spring from the
feelings of the democrats
this is the way that judges have been
nominated and confirmed since the
beginnings of
the republic a final correlator for this
on the republican side
ted cruz correctly points out that trump
has delivered on his promise which is
true
donald trump promised that he was going
to deliver textualist originalist judges
and he has
for the most part done that and where
he's made a mistake he's made a mistake
that other republicans have made
but trump has tried his damnedest here
is ted cruz pointing that out
today president donald trump delivered
on one of the central promises he made
to the american people
to nominate principled
constitutionalists to the u.s supreme
court
today the republican majority in the
united states senate delivered on one of
the principal promises
we made to the american people to
confirm
principled constitutionalist to the u.s
supreme court
to everyone who values and cherishes
the constitution and bill of rights
today was an important milestone
and that of course is true uh the fact
that trump
has now put in three supreme court
justices is a very good thing and the
fact that
those supreme court justices could
provide a bulwark against the predations
on the constitution that the left is
about to perform that that is certainly
a very good thing one of the
actual side results of this is that if
john roberts sides with the court's
liberals let's say that john roberts
decides to side with
stephen breyer and sonya sotomayor and
elena kagan and so you have a five-four
majority for the
so-called conservative justices well
guess who gets to assign the opinions
then
clarence thomas because clarence thomas
is the most senior associate justice
on the uh on the original side of the
aisle so this does radically shift the
court it does make a difference
in how the court makes decisions and
this is scaring the living hell out of
democrats
because democrats have always seen the
court as either
a green light for all of their most
bizarre policy preferences
or as actively fomenting left-wing
change they cannot get done via the
legislature
they've either seen the court as a place
where they can rewrite the law
post-facto in order to justify what they
would like to do of
obamacare or they have seen the court as
a an
obvious progressive tool of social
change as in obergefell
pushing forward same-sex marriage even
though the state legislatures have not
gone along with same-sex marriage yet
this is how they view the court and if
the court is taken away from them well
then they will take the ball and go home
and they're not talking about blowing up
the court which is no shock at all
what they are most afraid of of course
is that the court will rule along
textualist lines this scares the living
daylights out of them
and they become very clear about this
right ed markey
who is the senator from massachusetts
and a crazy socialist bernie sanders
type
he gave a speech yesterday in which he
said that originalism is just
discrimination
now originalism for those who don't know
anything about judicial philosophy
originalism is the very simple
proposition
that the constitution of the united
states is to be read as it was written
that doesn't magically change over time
when the constitution of the united
states it says that you have a right to
keep and bear arms for example
what that phrase means keep and bear
arms meant what it meant when it was
written
that it didn't magically transmute into
what ed markey would like it
to say that when the constitution of the
united states protects freedom of the
press
it means what it meant at the time when
the amendments of the constitution
are interpreted they mean what they said
that the amendment that allows women to
vote allows women to vote
that the amendment that preserves equal
rights for black americans preserves
equal rights for black americans right
these
these are amendments to the constitution
and they are to be interpreted as
written just like every other law is
meant to be interpreted
as written it is so weird that folks on
the left believe that judges
really are just supposed to be the great
moral arbiters of our time even though
they are
not elected even though they are
life-tenured if you really believe that
we should just have an aristocracy we
should just have a moral aristocracy
unanswerable to the people because these
are obviously
the best qualified and most moral among
us so here's ed markey suggesting
originalism is merely discrimination
originalism is racist originalism is
sexist
originalism is homophobic for
originalists
like judge barrett lgbt stands for let's
go back in time
a time when you couldn't marry who you
love
when you couldn't serve in the military
if you were trans a time when rights
were not extended to gay
lesbian bisexual transgender queer
questioning or
intersex individuals original
originalism is just a fancy word for
discrimination
that is a very stupid man i mean either
he's stupid or he's dishonest there
really is no third choice right there
because all originalism says that the
law means what it meant when it was
written and by the way
if you want there to be trans people in
the military all you have to do is pass
a law
that's all you have to do there's
nothing in the constitution that forbids
trans people from serving the military
if you want same-sex marriage all you
have to do is pass a law there's not a
single supreme court justice who has
ever suggested right left or center
that the constitution forbids same-sex
marriage right the constitution does not
forbid same-sex marriage
the constitution may not have mandated
same-sex marriage but there is a
difference between the constitution
mandating something and the constitution
forbidding something and this broad gray
area in american life where the
constitution is silent and does not
speak and where things are left to the
purview of the state and local
authorities
so what ed markey is trying to say is
that if you are a judge and you don't do
what ed markey likes
it's because you have actually you're a
bad person you see
this is the same disgusting argument you
hear with regard to free speech so if i
say that i'm pro-free speech
and i'm in favor of people being able to
speak freely without punishment
then this is like the argument that says
if you're pro-free speech this means
you're in favor of people shouting the
n-word
no i'm very much against people shouting
the n-word i'm very much against the
n-word i think it's evil i think the use
of it is evil
i also believe that you have a right to
do some evil things in the united states
because of freedom of speech does that
mean i'm in favor of people misusing
their rights no
okay but this is the argument that says
if government allows you to do a thing
or if the constitution allows you to do
a thing
therefore the constitution must be bad
so if the constitution
was written at a time when same-sex
marriage was not legal this means
that faithfully interpreting the
constitution makes you an emissary of
all those ideologies
whereas if you're really truly good what
you would do is you just discard the
constitution and do whatever you want
and what you knew to be right in your
own heart
there's only one problem that is not the
role of judges we have entire elected
legislative bodies for this
we have a president of the united states
for this we have elected branches of the
united states government
and state governments and local
governments to do the will of ed markey
judges are not made for that but again
if you view the court as your personal
preserve a place you ram through your
personal policy agenda you get quite mad
when it turns out that the court is not
going to do any of that
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about how you
protect yourself
online so it is pretty pretty obvious
pretty damned obvious at this point that
social media sites
are now seeking to target conservatives
social media sites are seeking to
limit the amount of information and the
kinds of information that you can see
places like twitter were supposed to be
an open platform instead their content
moderators
are upgrading particular content and
downgrading other content and
putting in particular fact checks
designed for you because you're bad and
you're conservative
instead of letting social media sites
revoke your right to free speech how
about revoking their right to your data
you could deactivate all your social
media accounts or you could continue to
use social media and just not let them
use
your data to monetize this is why i use
expressvpn if you've ever wondered how
free to access sites make all their
money the answer is they track your
searches video history and everything
you click on
and then they sell your valuable data
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers and
expressvpn could not be easier to set up
you tap one button on your phone
or computer you are now protected it's
finally time to say no to censorship
take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com slash ben
visit my special link we'll get an extra
three months of expressvpn service for
free
again that's expr essvpn.com
expressvpn.com ben to protect your
data today okay so democrats absolutely
lose it because they don't
believe in the traditional vision of the
courts they don't believe in federalist
78 where alexander hamilton called the
supreme court
the uh the least dangerous branch where
he declared the judiciary has neither
forced nor will
and that if it were disposed to start
exercising its will
instead of simple judgment it would lose
its reason for being they just disagree
with alexander hamilton they think that
the court
should basically just be another
democratic super legislature
and so now they are very very very upset
and they are suggesting that this thing
is illegitimate illegitimate by
illegitimate what they actually mean
is we don't like it so nancy pelosi
tweeted out president trump and senate
republicans have committed an act of
supreme desperation
jamming through a supreme court nominee
just eight days before election day as
part of their years-long campaign to
destroy americans healthcare
and first of all this is such a strange
reading amy coney barrett is not
striking down obamacare it's not a thing
that is going to happen
in fact she was on a moot court and she
didn't strike down obamacare
so democrats are immediately going to
results-driven jurisprudence you see
what they're doing here
the idea is amy coney barrett is bad
because she's not giving democrats what
they want
and it's not that she's not going to
faithfully interpret the law it's that
if she faithfully interprets the law
they might not get what they want this
is why democrats are going
nuts today right democrats are going
nuts similarly speaking
over a uh a 5-3 vote along ideological
lines last night there's a case called
the democratic national committee versus
wisconsin state legislature
the wisconsin state democratic national
committee had been pushing to allow
mail-in ballots to be counted
if they arrived as much as six days
after the polls closed
on election day a lower court had shot
down that plan
justice roberts joined the four
conservative justices in refusing to
overturn
their decision the lower court's ruling
will now stand the late ballots will not
be accepted so wisconsin cannot count
mail ballots that arrive
well after the polls close which makes
perfect sense because obviously it's
gonna be difficult to tell who is voting
after election day
and who is not democrats are very upset
about this
right again they see this as a political
move according to ian millhiser who is
one of the idiots over at vox.com he
says what is surprising is two
concurring opinions by justices neil
gorsuch
and brett kavanaugh each of which takes
him at one of the most foundational
principles
of american constitutional law the rule
that the supreme court of the united
states
has the final word on questions of
federal law but the highest court in
each state has the final word
on questions of state law this division
of power is implicit
in our very system of government so
they're saying the supreme court should
just overrule the wisconsin supreme
court
but um that's ridiculous this is the
supreme court
lets the states speak where the
constitution does not speak
and the constitution of the united
states certainly does not mandate that
votes be counted six days after the
election
but again democrats get angry at the
court when they don't get what they want
from the court
not when the court violates the
constitution but when they don't get
what they want
senator kamala harris tweeted out
similarly to nancy pelosi said we're not
going to forget this
we won't forget this says kamala harris
quote
today republicans denied the will of the
american people by confirming a supreme
court justice through an illegitimate
process okay it is perfectly legitimate
and by pulling data amy coney bear was
popular a plurality if not an outright
majority of americans wanted to see her
confirmed
she says all in their efforts to gut the
affordable care act and strip healthcare
from millions with pre-existing
conditions
we won't forget this again this is just
myth-making there's nothing in amy coney
barrett's record that suggests that
she's about to overturn obamacare it's
just nonsense
it's just absolute nonsense but again
scare the living hell out of americans
to justify everything you're about to do
is the name of the game okay understand
that this is where this is going
in order to get what they want democrats
are now basically suggesting
that the other side is engaged in
radical evil and this now justifies what
we're about to do if we pack the court
well that was your fault
if we decide that we are going to get
rid of the senate filibuster all
together well that's your fault guys you
started it
you now again the irony of this argument
cannot be overstated
democrats started this with regard to
judges they did it was democrats who
violated every prevailing norm for
generations
in order to get judges they want and to
reject justices they didn't like
but now their claim is that republicans
have violated the final war and
therefore all norms go away
good news all the norms are gone and
they can do everything they've wanted to
do for a very long time we'll get to
this in just
one second aoc making that mostly clear
we'll get to that
in one by the way i guess i'm not
supposed to call her aoc anymore she
says it's disrespectful to call her aoc
which is incredible because when it was
rbg
then that was a mark of affection right
you said rbg that was mark of affection
if you say aoc
then apparently this is disrespectful so
the honorable congresswoman alexandra
ocasio-cortez
d bartender she uh she is um
she has some words about what should
happen next year we'll get to that in
just one second
first from working to playing hard when
you start every morning in tommy john
underwear you are that much more
comfortable so you can do everything
better that is why tommy john underwear
doesn't just have customers
they have converts once you try tommy
john you will not go back it really is
fantastic stuff with breathable
lightweight moisture wicking fabric
with four times the stretch of competing
brands it moves with you tommy john
underwear comes with a non-rolling
waistband for the perfect fit the legs
never ride up you're covered with their
no
wedgie guarantee tommy john underwear is
listed on gq's latest 10 essentials with
kevin hart they have over 96 percent of
four star plus reviews over 12 million
pair sold there is a reason for that
because once you try tommy john i
promise you
you're not gonna want any other pair of
underwear they are indeed fantastic
they're also incredibly durable they go
through the wash
a lot and they feel great every single
time because tommy john underwear feels
so good
so free so barely there it's like going
commando but with no risk attached
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee means no risk try tommy
john if you don't love them
they are free having a great pair of
underwear you don't think about how
that's important
until you have a bad pair of underwear
and then you realize oh yeah that's
important
get much more comfortable at
tommyjohn.com say 15
on your first order say 15 percent right
now at tommyjohn.com
ben that's tommy john i love their
product my wife loves their product
tommy john's got stuff for everyone go
check them out tommyjohn.com
ben okay so aoc brings forth the threat
and she says that it's time to pack the
court but she doesn't just say it's time
to pack the court she explains why it's
time to pack the court again this is
also
part of the broader argument i'm sorry i
called her aoc again what i meant is the
honorable congresswoman
alexandra ocasio-cortez won a middle
school science contest
d so alexander ocasio-cortez she tweeted
out expand the court
now to be fair she's been claiming this
since some long before this nominee
she wants the court expanded because she
wants the court to basically just be a
rubber stamp for all of her policy
preferences
then she tweeted out republicans do this
because they don't believe democrats
have the stones to play hardball like
they do
and for a long time they've been correct
but do not let them bully the public
into thinking their bulldozing is normal
but a response isn't there is a legal
process for expansion
there is a legal process for expansion
it has not been used since 1869.
so the idea here is that republicans
violated a norm
by confirming a justice nominated by a
member of their own party in the
presidency
and therefore you get to explode the
number of justices on the supreme court
maybe just to troll aoc or i'm sorry the
honorable
congresswoman alexandra ocasio cortez
d 93 trillion dollar green new deal
maybe in order to troll her mitch
mcconnell should just expand the supreme
court now
i mean they've got their they've got the
majority why not why not just
let's like 300 judges let's just do it
right now expand the supreme court blow
up the entire institution
because if democrats can do it so can
republicans these rules apply
to everyone but the underlying theme
here
is the one that's important because this
is the argument democrats are going to
make as they violate every norm
and destroy every aspect of
institutional government in the united
states that is republicans are so
violative of norms they are so cruel
they are so they are so revolutionary
that our counter-revolution is necessary
in order to stop the kulaks we have to
stop the kulaks
because if we wish to march forward we
have to stop them from blowing up the
bridges
the saboteurs they're saboteurs so if we
glug them or execute them politically
speaking
well then all of that is called for
that's just what we're doing nancy
pelosi is on board as well she says
maybe we should expand the courts
maybe it's time it was a hundred
oh well in 1879 in 1876
there were nine justices on the court
our population has grown enormously
since then
should we expand the court well let's
take a look and see
but not and that relates to the nine uh
district courts maybe we need
more district courts as well
oh so maybe we should just add more like
more courts for everybody
okay so we're just gonna violate all of
the norms naturally my favorite is that
in order to cast this as unprecedented
chuck schumer
just keeps using the same line over and
over so back in 2017 he declared that
when the trump tax cuts went through it
was one of the darkest days in american
history
well apparently yesterday was also one
of the darkest days in american history
now
there have been a lot of dark days in
american history like there was that
time that fdr interned a hundred
thousand japanese americans
there was that time when for a hundred
years jim crow ruled in the south
there was that time when lynching was
fairly commonplace
across the south there was that time
when slaves were held americans were
held in bondage in the united states
i feel like there were some dark days in
american history like if i were just
going to look at like darkest days in
american history and list them off
yeah like i don't know the assassination
of abraham lincoln the killing of jfk
like
there are a fair number of bad things
that have happened in american history
i don't think confirmation of amy coney
barrett makes the top
any i'm pretty sure that that one's not
on the list but according to chuck
schumer two of the darkest days in
american history
were the trump tax cuts and amy coney
barrett joining the supreme court
i feel like the word darkest does not
mean what you think it means
i i like we're now in princess bride
land here
here is chuck schumer saying a silly
thing
my deepest greatest and most abiding
sadness tonight
is for the american people and what this
nomination
will mean for their lives
their freedoms their fundamental rights
monday october 26
2020 it will go down
as one of the darkest days in the 231
year history
of the united states senate spoiler
alert
it won't i mean spoiler alert right
there not not going to happen
chucky no not not really a thing okay
but again the
the goal here is to proclaim that this
is wildly out of bounds
the appointment of amy cooney barry is
so wildly out of bounds that everything
has to be broken
every breaking of every norm is now
absolutely justified
so in order to ratchet that up you have
to ratchet up the hysteria so for
example
chris hayes on msnbc he suggested that
amy coney barrett's confirmation led to
the deaths of a hundred thousand
americans
i'm not kidding that's the thing that
chris hayes actually said
and that is they have participated in a
project that has led the deaths of
probably a hundred thousand americans
who didn't have to die
congratulations you got that done too
that also can't be reversed
they can't come back we can't undo that
that's the other accomplishment here
judge barrett they traded one for the
other
they traded those lies for this justice
and they had a party about it in the
rose garden too
now okay but this is again it's part of
the broader narrative so the broader
narrative is
that the republicans broke all the
things so now we get to completely break
all the things
republicans broke the vase so now we're
just going to grind it into sand
so ezra klein has a piece over at
vox.com ezra klein
has decided that america's
constitutional structures are bad and of
no consequence
and the reason they're battered and of
no consequences is because they're not
perfectly democratic this is the same
case that
idiot jamal bowie at the new york times
has made which is that we should get rid
of all constitutional
checks and balances that we should just
have a pure majoritarian mob rule
in the united states because all of
these other tools of american democracy
and american republicanism
all they do is somehow dampen the will
of the people
all they do is hamper the ability of the
will of the people to be spoken
thoroughly and effectuated properly so
ezra klein writes
back in september mitch mcconnell is
changing the democratic party
he says senate democrats are learning
from it mitch mcconnell he will go down
as one of the most consequential senate
leaders in history said has reclined his
legacy isn't defined by bill's past or
pax struck
mcconnell's legislative record in terms
of both his accomplishments and those he
shepherded through as leader is meager
he's passed tax cuts cut regulations
confirmed judges he failed to repeal
obamacare shrink or restructure
entitlements or pass infrastructure or
immigration reform
historians will not linger long over the
laws mcconnell passed
as mcconnell himself has said his most
consequential decision was in act of
negation blocking merrick garland from
being appointed to the supreme court
mcconnell's legacy rather will be
transforming the united states senate
into a different institution
reflecting a different era in american
politics historically the senate has
been an institution unto itself
built around norms of restraint and
civility run according to informal
understandings and esoteric rituals
designed around the interests of
individuals
rather than the stratagems of parties
this is the senate mcconnell claimed to
revere
naming henry clay the so-called great
compromiser as his model and
promising a restoration of old
traditions this is the senate mcconnell
has eviscerated
through his own actions and those he has
provoked in the democrats uh you see you
see when democrats do things that
violate norms it's all because
mcconnell's mean you see
see this is it's the same excuse my kids
use when my daughter wallops my
four-year-old son
and i say why did you do that she always
says well he started it
right so the rule here is that if
democrats violate every single norm from
here on out it's all because mitch
mcconnell
evil cocaine mitch started all of this
he's a vessel for the currents and
forces of his time says ezra klein what
sets him apart is his fulsome embrace
of those forces his willingness to cut
through the cans and pretense of
american politics to stand a thwart
polarization
yelling faster oh it's mcconnell who
made polarization happen faster wasn't
harry reid after all
who destroyed the judicial filibuster it
wasn't the democrats who decided they
were going to filibuster judges in the
first place it's all
mitch mcconnell you see they started it
they did it first
and because they did it first that means
that we can violate every norm
none of the norms matter anymore it's a
short
line from there to ian millhiser idiot
vox.com
writing how an anti-democratic
constitution gave us amy coney baird
it's time to blow up the constitution
you see
because it turns out that the
constitution of the united states allows
senators
who are not elected by population you
see it allows senators
from sparsely populated states to select
supreme court justices and that's bad so
that means it's time for the senate to
go
according to ian millhiser while
pro-barrett senators control a majority
of the senate they represent nowhere
near a majority of the entire nation
indeed the senators who voted against
barrett represent 13 million 500 000
more people than the senators who voted
for her i delivered this figure using
2019 census estimates of each state's
population you can check my work using
this spreadsheet okay first of all
your work is stupid because it turns out
that the senators who represent those
states don't represent 100 of the
population of those states so if
somebody won a 5149 election
counting that entire state population as
one party or the other party is idiotic
but beyond that
even if that were not true even if you
were going to counter the way melheiser
is that is the purpose of the united
states senate
it was designed to create a check and
balance against overweening federal
power
done from the most populous centers of
the united states
but according to ian millhiser it is
time for the senate of the united states
to go
according to amy according to the
illustrious aoc sorry
the honorable congresswoman alexandra
ocasio-cortez
d dancing according to that according to
the honorable alexander cortez it's time
to to pack the courts
it's time to break all of the norms all
the norms it's time
because mitch mcconnell has created this
bad
very bad terrible world for us and as it
turns out this argument the democrats
are putting forth which is that we can
do whatever we want because republicans
started it
it now applies to everything up to and
including riots
as we will see there are big riots in
philadelphia last night
deadly riots in philadelphia last night
but don't worry
the only way to stop those riots is to
elect democrats because of course those
are somehow trump's fault
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you need a great couch so you've heard
me
talk ad nauseum on this program about my
helix sleep mattress
my helix sleep mattress is fantastic it
is the only way i get sleep with small
children
but helix has now gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
it's called all form they're making
premium customizable sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door so what
makes an all-form sofa really cool for
starters
is the easiest way you can customize the
sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain
scratch resistant i have kids all of
that super important you can pick the
sofa color the color of the legs sofa
size and shape to make sure it is
perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs they've got love
seats all the way up to an eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
you can always start small and then buy
more seats later on if you want your all
form sofa to grow and change with you
when you move
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping in the past if you wanted to
order a sofa
it could take weeks or even months to
arrive and you'd need someone to come
and assemble it in your home
all form takes just three to seven days
to arrive in the mail you can assemble
it's your
it yourself in a few minutes with no
tools necessary i've got an all-form
sofa
it's a three-seat sofa with chase in the
sand color with espresso legs it is mad
it's so comfortable by the way that when
guests sleep at our house very often
they prefer to sleep on the couch
rather than even sleeping on the bed
that's how good these things are if
getting a sofa without trying
sounds risky don't need to worry you get
100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that is more than three
months so find your perfect sofa check
out allform.com
they have a forever warranty literally
forever all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com.com go check them out
right now all form dot com slash ben
okay we're gonna get some more of this
in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
this has been an absolutely insane year
it feels like america's coming apart and
that's because
philosophically we are there are two
different philosophies of the united
states one believes that the government
is there
to provide you privileges all you have
to do is surrender all of your liberties
the other believes in the founding
philosophy of the united states
one philosophy believes that the culture
of the united states ought to be one of
dependent
one of demanding the other suggests that
american culture is reliant on
entrepreneurialism and tolerance for
other people's freedoms
one philosophy suggests that american
history is evil the other that american
history is good
my book how to destroy america in three
easy steps is about all of this it is
going to outlast the election
no matter what happens in the election
because this battle is going to outlast
the election i get the question all the
time what's a book i can give to my kids
give to my grandkids
to ensure that they understand what is
at stake so they can ensure
that they understand what america is all
about and what exactly is being fought
for in politics my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps is that book
i'm very proud of it i think it is a
i i think it is a very important book i
think it's an easy read very capable
of being read by kids who are in high
school and certainly by adults
go pick up a copy right now how to
destroy america in three easy steps also
the presidential election it's almost
here we have an amazing day of
programming
just for you our live streaming starts
on tuesday november 3rd at 3 p.m eastern
12 p.m pacific we're going to be with
you all
day long it features special guests live
interviews and more
leading up to a very special episode of
saved by the bell
in which we learn about substance abuse
no actually it leads up to a very
special episode of backstage
where we will be covering the results
with you in real time even better
join dailywire right now get 25 off with
code election
so you can watch all of our election
coverage live on our apple tv or roku
app again that's daily wire and get 25
off with code election no jeffrey tube
but not co-direction code election
at 25 off members get our articles ad
free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show exclusive readers past
content
available only to dailywire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership
you get to join us on all access live
every night for online and live stream
discussions
you also get not one but you leftist
year's tumblers with your membership as
well as early sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products so watch the
election with us at dailywire.com and
get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
this is the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
all right so again the argument from the
left is everything is justified because
trump is bad and republicans are bad
and so everything is justified and this
extends to the realm of rioting
it does and apparently the only way to
stop all this is of course to concede to
the left
right it's a beautiful circular logic
here republicans caused us to do bad
things
the only way to stop us from doing bad
things is to elect us
to do bad things but that can only be
stopped if you elect us
and then we do bad things because
republicans do bad things and so
the circle goes okay so overnight there
were multiple reports in philadelphia
that 30 police officers had been injured
in riots following a fatal police
shooting
police responded to a domestic call just
before 4 pm on monday video shows
officers with guns drawn in a
neighborhood
initial reports said that a man named
walter wallace was armed with a knife
and refused calls to drop the weapon
you can hear officers yelling put the
knife down multiple times
videos show the officer shooting this
person multiple times
wallace was pronounced dead at the scene
a statement released from the mayor
and police commissioner said the
shooting was under investigation it does
not indicate whether it was confirmed
that wallace was armed apparently he was
mayor jim kenney said i've watched the
video of this tragic incident it
presents difficult
questions that must be answered i
recognize the video of the incident
raises many questions as police
commissioner daniel
outlaw no it doesn't it raises zero
questions
you can see the video the person at
issue is holding a knife
he refuses to put it down he approaches
the police officers when he is about 10
feet away refusing to put down the knife
they shoot him
because you know what you don't have to
do when you are an officer with a gun
wait for the person to come six inches
from you and then stab you in the
freaking face
that's a thing you don't have to do as a
police officer in fact
you know what the advantage of a gun is
for those who need this this little
lecture
you know what an advantage of a gun is
you can shoot people from far away
you know what negates the advantage of a
gun when the person's right up next to
you you stupid asses
i don't under like so the people what
were they supposed to do throw their gun
at him
the guy was approaching them with a
knife we have now reached the point
where the shooting doesn't even have to
be remotely unjustifiable to justify
rioting in our streets because america
is so
obscenely racist apparently apparently a
police sergeant was run over by a truck
so you got a lot of delightful people
engaging in this sort of violence
all i can hope is that rural
pennsylvania shows up in droves
in droves to elect donald trump to
prevent this sort of stuff
from being okayed by city authorities
according to the police department at
least 12 at philly police officers were
hospitalized with various injuries
one of them was a a 56 year old female
sergeant
she was a 56 year old female sergeant
okay where's the defend all women crowd
56 year old female sergeant hit by a
black
pickup truck in stable condition with a
broken leg other officers were injured
and bricks were thrown at them but you
know they're just bricks
no big deal they're just bricks who
cares just bricks
but you know what if you hate all this
if you hate wokeness if you hate the
the woke left and the radical left the
only way to stop all of this
uh the only way to stop all of this is
to vote for joe biden
see how this works because the right has
driven the left so crazy
that now the only way to stop the left
from being crazy is to elect the left to
power
the only way to stop the wokeness is to
not elect donald trump is to elect joe
biden
who is enthralled to the radical left
this is the logic of a columnist who i
mean very frequently i actually like
yasha monk over the atlantic
he has a piece today titled trump is the
best candidate for the illiberal left
if you hate wokeness you should vote joe
biden
okay as as one twitter commentator put
it if you
hate your headache you should stab
yourself directly in the eye with an ice
pick
if you hate wokeness you should elect
joe biden all right
well let's hear let's hear it out a
number of influential commentators who
firmly opposed donald trump in 2016
recently announced their intention to
vote for him in 2020. nearly all of them
including james lindsey daniel pletka
and ben shapiro blamed
liberalism on the left as shapiro said
on his popular show he was planning to
vote for trump because democrats have
lost their effing minds
accurate quote concerned about illiberal
tendencies on the left are not made up
out of thin air
many democratic politicians have not
been as full-throated in their
opposition to left-wing political
violence as they should be oh you think
you mean like how joe biden refuses to
condemn antifa to this day
and nobody seems to ask a follow-up
question we'll get one million questions
from our compliant media about donald
trump and white supremacists even though
trump has condemned white supremacists
at this point
1 million 223 221 times
at last count but joe biden still has
not
achieved the signal moral feat of
condemning antifa
a group that goes around firing laser
pointers at
federal officers eyes yash amongst his
parts to the left now seek far-reaching
censorship and social media advocate for
employers to be fired
employees to be fired for expressing
conservative opinions and are openly
hostile to free speech
the likely future mayor of portland
oregon has appeared to glorify mass
murderers such as che guevara and mao
zedong on the campaign trail
but the fact is that trump presents a
much greater danger to key
constitutional values
and does more than anyone else to lend
apparent credibility to extreme forms of
protest
as well as an unremittingly negative
appraisal of america
voting for trump to stem the rise rising
tide of liberalism is about as pure and
example of cutting off your nose despite
your face as political life can afford
ah you see this is all trump's fault
because the liberals were not in charge
until donald trump came to office
which neglects the fact that once again
for the millionth time
the world did not begin spinning when
donald trump became president
illiberalism on the left was very much a
thing
while barack obama was president of the
united states it was rising then
it rose dramatically in the aftermath of
hillary clinton's laws
there were riots in the streets while
barack obama was president of the united
states and barack obama was tutting
violence against police officers
right police violence against police
officers bad it's not good but systemic
racism
infects all of our police departments
the illiberalism on the left is not a
new thing
but according to yasha monk the only way
to stop it is to elect people who are
who are immediately going to cave to the
liberals on the left
yashimong says most americans at all
attentive to politics can recite a long
list of trump's verbal attacks on
democracy
trump has called for both hillary
clinton his competitor in 2016 and joe
biden his current adversary to be locked
up
he claims the 2016 election was marred
by fraud even though he won and now
refuses to commit to a peaceful transfer
of power should he lose
okay well yes that is uh that is true
and also it is true that he has done
none of those things
right he does run the doj none of those
things have happened as it turns out
trump as i've said one uh i keep
repeating myself here but it's true
donald trump on his epitaph it will say
45th president of the united states he
set a lot of bleep
he did a lot of good stuff he also set a
lot of bleep we are well aware
but i'm not going to treat every trump
pronouncement as serious when he is an
utterly unserious person in his
pronouncement
okay but according to yasha monk he says
apologists who say trump barks much
louder than he bites make an important
point
while trump's twitter feed would make
any dictator proud the actions of his
government have been less
nakedly autocratic trump has not tried
to imprison biden or shut down the new
york times
and although he has repeatedly denounced
the judiciary he has mostly proved
willing to be bound by their rulings
yes but if trump's words are worse than
his actions his actions have still been
outrageous
trump has repeatedly interfered in the
process of awarding federal contracts
and approving corporate mergers to
punish companies that have dared to
criticize him
yes that is bad you're right it is bad
and you know who would continue to do
all of that stuff
biden because barack obama literally did
that barack obama in the early years of
his administration
said two members of the banking
community
the pitchforks are outside you have to
do what i say i'm the only thing that
stands between you and the pitchfork
that's an actual thing said by president
barack obama directly to members of the
banking community
in 2009 he has made a legal payment
possibly using campaign contributions to
women with whom he has had affairs
okay well illegal payments to people you
have affairs with is disgusting
it also is not a threat to the
constitutional order he has fired
inspectors general of federal
departments when they have uncovered
wrongdoing by members of his
administration okay that is under
controversy
also it is true that barack obama did
that so here's the thing if you're going
to claim that donald trump is a unique
threat to liberty
that is not posed by the democratic
party you can't keep saying things where
i can say barack obama did the same
thing
you have to create a point of
differentiation barack obama fired a
prosecutor
an independent prosecutor who is
investigating his friend kevin johnson
then the mayor of sacramento
for corruption and barack obama was no
wilting lily when it came to using the
powers of government in corrupt ways
he has invoked a fake national emergency
to redirect federal funds toward a
political pet project the wall at the
southern border
as opposed to barack obama who literally
just rewrote immigration law
himself he has used the resources of his
office to boost companies of friends and
allies has channeled significant sums of
money
into his own properties okay that last
one about
secret service spending money at his
hotels is it
yucky yes it is yucky is it perfectly
within the line of swamp creature crap
that presidents and politicians have
done for a long time again i don't see
how that is any more yucky that really
than joe biden engaging in a process
whereby his son and his brothers are
enriched with use of his personal name
while he's vice president of the united
states
these attacks on america's
constitutional traditions don't mean
trump is about to pronounce himself
emperor for life nor do they mean he'll
manage to stay in office if he loses the
upcoming election but they should make
removing him from office the top
priority for any voter who is genuinely
concerned about the rise of illiberal
forces
okay well now you're going to have to
explain why i shouldn't be worried about
the rise of the liberal forces
when the left that pats them on the head
is in power
many of the most worrying tendencies
says yahshua monk on the left stem from
two intellectual mistakes
the first is to focus so tightly on the
country's flaws that its strength
become invisible and its institutions
dispensable the second is to believe the
right poses such an imminent danger any
form of resistance against it is
justifiable even if it involves
violence trump disagrees with both of
these mistakes but because he is
genuinely dangerous and extraordinarily
polarizing he makes it harder for
establishment institutions to hold their
ground against these fallacies
uh you see because trump is so unique
democrats have lost their minds so get
rid of trump and democrats will
immediately snap back to being
clintonian liberals okay this neglects
the entire history of the democratic
party from barack obama on
they stopped being clintonian liberals a
long time ago bernie sanders was nearly
their nominee
in 2020. this is not the party of bill
clinton if bill clinton ran on his 1992
platform
right now you'd probably be running as a
republican okay this is not a party of
liberalism it is not a party of open
debate it is a party of censorship and a
censorship approved at the highest
levels kamala harris is the left
most senator in the united states senate
she is not
some raving moderate joe biden is not a
raving moderate
he was a left-wing member of the senate
before he was vice president as vice
president he was extremely left-wing
and he showed no like seriously no
compunction about going along with
barack obama's various excesses
but the basic idea here is that if you
worry about a liberalism on the left
then you should vote for joe biden
yashman concludes according to
commentators such as shapiro
progressives already hold power in
universities in the mainstream media in
hollywood and silicon valley
if they also captured congress in the
white house they would gain virtually
unified control of american politics
and culture but fears of a biden
presidency leading to a woke takeover
misunderstand the way public opinion
moves in america
because trump's ample failings have
given the most misguided claims of the
far left a superficial veneer of
plausibility
trump himself has been the far left's
biggest ally so in other words trump
drove the left crazy so get rid of trump
and they will stop being crazy
i don't believe this for one heartbeat i
don't it preceded trump it will go on
after trump and if you believe that
kamala harris
and the illustrious honorable
congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez d jeremy corbyn
that she is going to just go away that
the democratic party is going to go back
to being
a mainstream liberal party you got
another thing coming
and by the way i'm not willing to bet on
the good graces of strangers okay i'm
not blanched
wah politically speaking i'm not going
to sit around going i rely on the
kindness of strangers
as the democratic party runs roughshod
through the political system not when
they are
open and openly threatening to do all
this stuff they don't go back to
moderation
that's not a thing that's going to
happen the moderate democratic party is
gone barack obama being portrayed as a
moderate within its own party as
evidence
that the moderate democratic party is
completely gone once you suggest that
donald trump is responsible for every
evil
conservatives are responsible for every
evil and that all you have to do is hand
them power it's an act of political
blackmail
there's been no sister soldier speech
from joe biden anywhere in here and it's
not coming
because it's no longer inside the
democratic party they're not capable of
it
okay meanwhile the lie continues that
kovit is all donald trump's fault
that if it had been for if it had not
been for donald trump many hundreds of
thousands of people would still
be alive and it is amazing how openly
political and nakedly political
this particular narrative has become
okay so donald trump
uh the the his chief of staff mark
meadows said over the weekend
that we are not going to control the
pandemic this is a statement of fact
i will note that joe biden said in
debate with donald trump that donald
trump has to stop at the happy talk
right he said donald trump he needs to
stop with all of this happy talk we're
dying man
come on man we're dying man tell the
people the truth man
come on man okay well
mark meadows told people the truth this
pandemic is not going to be brought
under control
by lockdowns this pandemic is going to
continue
and you can social distance and you can
wear a mask and you can go about your
daily life
and that is about all you can do and we
have new treatments that are coming
online
we have antibodies that are coming
online as body treatments therapeutics
that are coming online we'll have a
vaccine by the end of the year
but this ain't going to stop anytime
soon this was treated by the media as
throwing up a white flag
i said oh you're throwing up a white
flag against letters so okay so let me
just get this straight
if you say the same thing that joe biden
said which is hundreds of thousands of
people will die by the end of the year
and you're a democrat this is you
telling hard truths to the american
people
if you're mark meadows and you say we
can't control the spread of the virus
because it is a contagious disease
then this is you throwing up the white
flag now donald trump
uh went after joe biden yesterday he
said you know you keep saying that i'm
waving the white flag on covid
joe biden has waved the white flag on
life dude's living in a basement
no no he has he's waved a white flag on
life
he doesn't leave his basement this guy
doesn't leave his basement
he is uh he's a pathetic candidate i
will tell you that
okay well he is not wrong about that if
there's ever been
honestly if joe biden goes on to win at
that point you do have to suggest
that fate has chosen joe biden because
seriously
the economy is going great guns up until
the pandemic the pandemic hits
and not only does it destroy the economy
in the united states
not only does it throw the trump
administration into even further levels
of confusion it also allows joe biden
to run an entire campaign doing zero
things and welding himself physically to
a couch
and that's an amazing thing and people
are saying he's run a smart campaign he
hasn't run a campaign
he hasn't even stumbled the campaign joe
biden has not moved
from within a 30-foot radius of his sofa
for like six months and he's if he wins
that is solely due to the covenant so i
mean
trump is not wrong about all of this but
again the myth making for the democratic
party
is that if it were not for the evil
trump administration all problems would
have been solved so hillary is back
which is just what we all needed i think
what america needed was more hillary
clinton i'm very excited so she was
talking with kara swisher kara swisher
she spends her days basically just
following people like me on twitter and
then complaining that people like me
exist
she literally said to susan wash kiki a
few years ago that if she could
she would ban me from youtube because
her son watches the show hey karis
wishes kid
has a gun karen swisher kara swisher
interviewed hillary clinton
and uh and hillary clinton said that she
was she was born
the saddest thing about her not being
elected president she was born to handle
the pandemic yeah i'm sure i'm sure that
hillary clinton was born to handle the
pandemic
i'm sure young hillary dreamed about
handling pandemics here is hillary
clinton
back from the political graveyard do you
think the woman
president in the united states would
handle the pandemic better
i have no doubt especially if it were me
no i mean
i was born for that okay that is the
stupidest question i maybe have ever
heard
do you think that a female would have
handled the pandemic better
would a female have handled the pandemic
better
um first of all define female kara
like i think we always have to start
with that premise because
we have now learned that the no that
females do not exist there literally is
no definition of female
it is anybody who identifies as a female
so what material quality of being female
would make you better at handling a
pandemic are you saying kara swisher
that women are better caretakers than
men because that seems kind of sexist to
me
are you saying that women organize
things differently than men because that
frankly seems kind of stereotypical
but i love that hillary clinton's like
yes if it had been me i would have
handled the pandemic so much differently
how nobody has an answer again this is
the myth making
the good news is that for democrats
basically they just say all the things
that we would have done normally would
have handled the pandemic
so jane fonda who is of course one of
our nation's illustrious minds
uh jane fonda who when she was not
climbing aboard
a a north vietnamese anti-aircraft gun
uh and doing propaganda work on behalf
of an evil regime
uh she was she was doing her workout
tapes and tightening the buns of
millions of women across america now
she's interviewing alexander
ocasio-cortez
who uh is most famous for playing silly
video games online while lots of people
watch
and uh and the illustrious aos i keep
doing this over and over and over
i'm sorry the honorable congresswoman
alexandra ocasio-cortez
d twitch alexander ocasio-cortez
she says you know what would have been
better you know to solve the pandemic if
we passed the green new deal yep
spending 93 trillion dollars on stupid
bull that definitely would have solved
the pandemic
probably good good answer aoc one of my
favorite things about democratic
policies is that you ask them okay how
would you have done this differently and
they're like
all the things i normally do would have
done it differently like hillary clinton
just by being hillary clinton would have
solved the pandemic
according to aoc the green new deal
solves all of the things
here is aoc the uh the honorable
congresswoman
alexandra ocasio-cortez d
rolling stone cover explaining
do you think that had there been a green
new deal in place in january 2020 covet
19 would have been much easier to
contain
and our health care system would have
been much more resilient
you know i absolutely think so for a lot
of reasons one
is that if we had passed a green new
deal
um by january of this year that would
mean that we had a political
establishment that respects science
that is willing to mobilize and make
major investments to protect
the american people
the utter insane stupidity of this if we
passed a green new deal that would have
meant that we respect science
we respect it science it's very
respectable and the way that we know we
respect science is women don't exist
babies don't exist until they are born
and also if we that climate change is an
existential threat to humanity all of
humanity
it's an existential threat you know it
people oh well the green new deal means
we respect science
god if she's just a slogan machine
that's all she is she's a bumper sticker
slogan machine
and this is considered the solution to
covet if you believe this stuff
honestly you deserve what you get i'm
gonna keep going with that that h.l
mankind quote
the democracy is the theory that
americans deserve to uh get what they
elect good and hard
that's you deserve this i mean honestly
you the american people you decide to
elect this to power
we're all getting what what you deserve
is is where this is going
okay meanwhile worthy of note the media
continue to cover for uh for everything
democratic
including joe biden of course i will say
that there have been a couple of
outstanding examples
of the media covering for the democratic
party the use of fact checkers as the
democratic party cover story is
incredible now
so there's been this lie that's been
going around for years that these fact
check sites are completely unbiased
politifact and factcheck.org and
snopes.com
they're not politically unbiased they
are all staffed by members of the left
and this is becoming
perfectly obvious in every possible way
youtube
hey youtube is now using factcheck.org
they're now using independent fact
checks from snopes.com
to back joe biden so if you search on
youtube
for joe biden and fracking a fact check
comes up an independent fact check comes
up from snopes.com
did biden propose a ban on fracking
rating mostly false
so now if you even search for things
about joe biden youtube is preemptively
white knighting
on behalf of joe biden that's exciting
by the way the same thing does not apply
to the steele dossier if you search
steele dossier there's no fact check
suggesting anything about the steele
dossier even though that thing is a
piece of
russian disinformation so that was one
just
note on fact checking the fact check
organizations that are being used to
launder left-wing values into social
media
right youtube google facebook twitter
they're all using these
left-wing fact check organizations to
push propaganda they say well
if the fact checker says it's not a fact
we obviously can't push it
okay who fact checks the fact checkers
the answer is nobody
because the left will not allow that
they just call it a fact check when it
really is just a left-wing opinion piece
my favorite example of this though was
not the youtube thing it was
a a fantastic fact check yesterday from
meg kelly
at the washington post so i'm gonna play
you a clip this is a clip of joe biden
suggesting that george w bush is still
president okay that is what it suggests
then we'll get to the fact check okay
because what i'm saying according to
the washington post fact checker is a
four pinocchio claim
four pinocchios okay that is that is a
4.0 if i say that this is joe biden
mixing up george w bush
and donald trump that is a four
pinocchio claim here's the entire clip
if someone is undecided or maybe
maybe you're thinking about not voting
why should they vote and why should they
vote for you
well first of all the reason they should
vote is that there's a lot on
on the ballot this year i mean this is
the most consequent not because i'm
running
but because who i'm running against it's
the most consequential election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh is going to find ourselves
in a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're going
to be we're going to be in a different
world
okay so um four more years of george
okay and
jill if you can't see this because
you're listening jill mouths the word
trump
she mouths it right so she she knows
that he has gaffed and that he has said
george w bush
because she mouths it in the middle of
the clip here is the washington post
fact check
no biden did not confuse george w bush
and donald trump
the video clip that republican national
committee rapid response director steve
guest tweeted late sunday night
seemed to be the stuff of opposition
researchers dreams just 27 seconds long
it appeared to show democratic
presidential nominee joe biden
criticized former president george w
bush as the person he is running against
the snippet
seemed to be evidence of a nasty theory
the trump campaign has been pushing for
months joe biden is senile okay that
the facts the i will vote concert was
hosted by comedian george lopez
and political commentator anna navarro
the segment begins with what looks like
a fancy zoom call
navarro and lopez are each in a separate
frame as are the bidens and a sign
language interpreter
lopez asked biden why undecided
americans should vote and vote for him
as biden begins his answer to the frames
of environment are dropped from the
screen and then there's the long quote
from joe biden then he stutters four
more years of george
george uh he uh are going to find
ourselves in a position where if
trump gets elected uh we are going to be
uh going to be in a different world
or was it four more years george george
uh we
uh it's hard to tell okay this is the
washington post fact checker
by the way seem to make fun of joe biden
stuttering which i which is
kind of gross right with his caption
guest answers an unspoken question of
just who
who is george suggesting that biden
confused trump with former president
george
w bush but viewers have no idea that
biden could have been referring to
george lopez who had originally asked
the question
biden spokesman andrew bates said he was
addressing george lopez the interviewer
as is a common practice no he clearly is
not
i'm sorry he is not if your defense to
this is
we need four more years of george lopez
then i'm gonna need to know exactly how
you think that makes sense
four more years of george are going to
find ourselves in position
where uh if trump gets okay so the
washington post gave it four pinocchios
to suggest that joe biden mixed up
donald trump and george by the way
joe biden has mixed up whether he was
running for senate or president of the
united states
he's mixed up which university he went
to he's mixed up which state he is in
and he has mixed up before people in the
audience
he for years has been doing this sort of
stuff he literally said during the
obama administration he said to a man
who was wheelchair-bound he asked him to
stand
up at an actual event that is the thing
that happened john's been doing this for
years but it's a washington post fact
check now
so if i say this then maybe youtube will
slap a fact check on me
for playing you the entire clip and then
explaining to you the entire context
i will be fact check now the use by the
media of these fake fact checkers
in order to stop anybody from
disseminating in
a different point of view is truly ugly
and it is just left-wing white-knighting
end of story okay we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
justice amy coney barrett is confirmed
and sworn in to the supreme court joe
biden admits to committing voter fraud
and a crazy lady pestered her dying
father into voting democrat
and then more riots in philadelphia
just days before the election check it
out on the michael knowles show
[Music]